créé dans les alpes un attrayant 800 qui
reliait dubaï à paris au moins 300
passagers
tu as pu avoir accès aux données à 15 et
la trajectoire mais l'appareil a piqué
rapidement ça a été très brutal
les experts du bea ont été dépêchés sur
les lieux de l'accident pour tenter de
localiser les boîtes noires
peinture je peux soit le connaître
l'enchaînement exact c'est vraiment
c'est bon c'est exploitable
atténue le moteur dans le médium
on sent très beau sur ce qu'on entend
on va tenter
j'ai des doutes sur le crash
ya un problème avec la boîte noire
a été falsifiée savent a intérêt à avoir
raison
je comprends pas qu'on ait pu lui
confier l'enquêté n'a encore entendu des
sons fantôme
j'ai vu vous êtes j'ai signalé des
problèmes de gouverne sur le 800
ya eu un attentat des premiers à l'avoir
entendu que j'ai entendu c'est une
[ __ ] de suite d'incohérences c'est en
train de se monter la tête la vérité sur
le crash pour la connaît
vous êtes allé trop loin
ce que tu as fait tu l'as fait pour toi
ils prêts à marcher dessus pour prouver
tes délires
[Musique]